Ready to go. The media and a fair number of
politicians act like the US and China are
at each other's economic throats. In fact,
the US probably helped China more at the
end of the Trump administration than it did
at the beginning. It's true we've hit China
with tariffs. The tariffs are overblown. In
2016, Donald Trump attacked the trade deficit
for sending billions of dollars to China. The
US-China deficit was 310 billion dollars then;
in 2020 it was 288 billion dollars. Much more
money is headed to China in a different way.
American holdings of Chinese stocks and bonds
were worth 104 billion dollars at the end of 2016.
At the end of 2020 they were worth 287 billion.
Including investment running through the Cayman
Islands adds 300 billion more in just those
four years. The trade deficit drop means nothing
and the US government isn't even sure how this
money is ultimately being used: to repress human
rights or help the Chinese military are ugly
possibilities. Some is certainly used to make
china more competitive. There are many plans to
outcompete China. None of them will work if huge
amounts of American money keep helping China
outcompete us. Should the US be doing more to
confront China? Let us know in our poll. Also let
us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.